hi my name is torn or B and I work on
the tools Android team so today I want
to show you the brand new IDE that we
have for Android as you can see here it
looks sort of dark
that's a optional dark theme that a lot
of us have liked a lot and on the left
here you can see the project Explorer
which shows you the files in your
project then we have the code editor in
the center and the code editor is really
the star of this IDE it is a very very
intelligent editor that can do really
really fast refactoring code completion
and so forth and I want to show a few of
those edit features in detail today
alright so here we're looking at some
pretty typical Android code but notice
that we have some hard-coded strings
here or what appear to be hard-coded
strings turns out they're actually not
this IDE can present these strings as if
they had been hard-coded so you can see
here as I hover I can see the real code
I can click on it and I can go in and
actually look at the real string but the
ID gives me a much simpler view of the
code which makes it a lot easier to read
and we don't just do that for Strings if
you look further down here you can see
we are manipulating some icons and over
in the gutter on the left you can see
the real icon itself and we also help
you with the completion here so if I
invoke code completion or and just do
show doc with f1 you can see we get this
completion dialog which shows me all the
assets as well and that works not just
for icons but for strings as well so if
I for example click on on this one you
can see we have actually we only have
two translations for that string and
furthermore this all also works on
colors so if I jump to for example the
color file you can see that we see all
the colors previewed in the gutter let's
take a look at the code again one of the
really nice things about this new IDE is
that it does really deep code analysis
so if I for example scroll to the bottom
here you can see that it has highlighted
this line and it's saying that this is a
potential nullpointerexception the
reason it knows that is that we have
added annotations into the Android
platform so we know which methods can
return all which methods can't and in
fact we also know for example which
constants are allowed
which api's so it is flagging this call
right up here to set layout direction
right which looks good but you can see
it's telling me that the concept we were
expected the pass in here is one of
these named constants and so we use this
data not just for code analysis but for
code completion as well so for example
context get system service you now if I
invoke code completion you can see it's
offering all the valid strings which is
a which is something we couldn't do in
the past you can invoke actions using
the show action dialog so I'm going to
type inspect code and you can see
inspect code lets me run on the whole
project or individual files and this is
how you basically run code inspections
and we've integrated lint so you get all
the lint errors but you also get a lot
of code analysis that IntelliJ already
comes with and it's really great at
finding a lot of bugs in your code now
let's talk about layout so if I jump
into a layout file like this one you can
see that we now offer you a preview on
the right of the layout and this preview
stays in sync with my edits so if I for
example click on this text right here
and I change the text let's see what
should we change it to about to reset
you can see the preview updates on the
left and the key thing about this
preview is you get to work with a code
but it keeps the the rendering on the
right and sync and you can also click in
the editor or in the preview and it
syncs the selection between the two
let's go ahead and create a new layout
so I'm going to create a new blank
layout so when I'm typing new layout
tags you can see that it actually helps
me complete my layout on the right so
the error panel is saying hey you have
this widget that you're missing a size
so we can just click on the link to have
it do that if I make a typo it detects
that and offers to fix it and this is
basically done for a lot of typical
errors that you might have as you're
editing your layouts another feature we
have is a multi configuration editing so
if I jump back to my stopwatch layout
here I can turn on the ability to see
this layout across a number of different
layouts and I do that you can see we
actually get a preview here of what the
current
I'm editing looks like here we have it
on a tablet a large tablet we have it
all the way from a 3.7 inch phone up to
you know a 4.7 inch Galaxy Nexus it's
showing the nexus 4 on the top left and
we have a 7-inch tablet in the 10-inch
tablet so this makes it very easy as I'm
editing you know to see if I'm making
any mistakes and this isn't just for
screen sizes we have many other aspects
so I can for example switch to
translations here I can see this layout
across a number of different languages
and so forth and again as I'm editing it
will generate previews of what the what
the edits look like so I can make sure
that I for example don't cause the the
text to crop on these different
languages so that's layout preview we
have this not just for for XML editing
you obviously if you prefer you can do
you can do layout editing with a full UI
builder as well this is something we're
still working on but as you can see here
we have our UI builder with a property
sheet palette and so forth and and
layout preview should work here as well
and I can go ahead and make my edits and
as you can see the the previews will
update and the reason that this one
didn't is because this is using a
different layout so we have a custom
landscape layout here that's used when
you have a large tablet it was one of
the ways you can make sure that your app
looks good across all the way from
phones or tablets is to use dedicated
layouts and creating new layouts in this
IDE is very easy we basically have this
create other item in the layout editor
which takes the current layout creates a
copy of it then you can customize that
for the specific form factor you have in
mind so there are a lot of new features
to investigate in this IDE this is just
a preview build the please give it a try
and let us know what you think thanks
for your time